the white house officials work to get  more americans to roll up their sleeves  and get vaccinated pfizer is now asking  the fda for emergency use authorization  for its vaccine for children ages 5  through 11. eight-year-old sebastian  freibold took part in pfizer's clinical  trial  it makes me very happy  that  i am helping other kids get the vaccine  studies show the heavy toll the pandemic  is taking on children they currently  make up more than a quarter of new covet  cases and new research finds more than  140 000 children have lost a caregiver  to covet 19. look i know the vaccination  requirements are tough medicine  i'm popular with some politics for  others  but they're life-saving they're game  changing for our country the fda is  promising quick action on pfizer's  vaccine for children saying a panel will  meet later this month to debate the  evidence  the children's vaccine is a lower dose  aversion now pfizer says its study found  no serious side effects